ONE OF THE CENTERING
FEED, SHOT, BLOCKED, DOWN ASSAS
A SHOT JUST INSIDE THE BLUE
WORINSKY, OFF THE S LEFT IN THE
PERIOD.
BOUNCED IN BY
TU DALLAS
TONIGHT.
THAT STORY LINE WILL HAVE TO
WAIT. CHANCES FROM
IT. OF
OFFENSE.
BENN
SHOVED BY BENN.
AND THAT PASS, LOGO
ON THE SWEATER.
>> EQUATION HERE
A SHOT UP HIGH.
IT RATTLES THE
OF THE NET TO THE
SHOOTS IT
PRIOR TO IT.
AND THEN YOU GET REWARDED.
THATAT
THE FENCE. AIRLINES
CENTER.
AFTER THE TWO TALLIES, FIRST
SEGUGU A
3-2 TWO
DALLAS
SHORT SIDE BID AND WENT WIDE TO
THE CIRCLE A SHOT AND
SQUEEZING THE PADS TOGETHER TO
COVER IT.
>> IT'S AN LAST DOZEN GAMES.
INCLUDING THE TALLY TY AGAINST
J
JAMIE BENN, POWER PLAY, EITHER
SIDE, HIS
EVENING.
DEFLECTS TO THE CORNER.
HANDLY, SECOND OPPORTUNITY, HE
>> 8:30 LEFTER 5 TO GO IN
THE THIRD PERIOD.
JUST ABOUT 27 FOR HEISKANEN.